F: C'est la dédicace à Taupe 10
S: *rires* ah taupe m'en 5 !
il faut que tu saches que j'ai un énorme problème avec mes cheveux
c'est toujours une horreur
F: C'est vrai
S: Ouais
F: Ben ouais mais estimes toi heureux de ne pas avoir ça en fait
Bienvenue dans notre tuto beauté
*rires*
F: Put**n il y a encore un grand sur ma chaîne *rire*
j'en ai marre
Tu sais que mes abonnés pensent que je suis petit
S: Non en plus pas tellement
F: C'est vous qui êtes beaucoup trop grand
S: Ouais c'est pas faux
*Générique*
F: Salut, aujourd’hui je suis avec Simon, Simon le jeu vidéal vous connaissez pas et bien cliquez parce que c'est cool
Avec Simon on se connait à peu près depuis le début d'année
On a lancé notre chaîne quasi en même temps
et on s'est suivi, on s'est envoyé des petits messages
et enfin on se voit parce que tu étais à la Paris Games Week
En fait, les trucs de mentalismes on ne t'invite jamais
parce qu'ils savent pas encore que j'existe
*rires*
S: Bientôt tu les mentaliseras tous.
Ils seront là "Viens avec nous, viens"
Donc toi tu es spécialisé sur les jeux vidéos sur ta chaîne,
d'une manière originale et c'est pour ça que j'ai suivi depuis le départ.
On n'est pas sur une chaîne typique Gaming
S: Qu'est ce qu'on peut retenir finalement, une fois qu'on a posé la manette.
Qu'est ce que j'ai retenu et pourquoi le jeu m'as plu, tu vois
F: Je ne peux pas jouer, un peu, aux jeux vidéos
S: Faut que tu...
F: Ça n'existe pas, je ne peux que perdre ma vie
*Rires*
S: Il y a pas d'entre deux
F: Ah ouais je me transforme en malade.
Tu sais les 1er jeux multijoueurs donc Dofus
[imite les abonnés] "Quoi il jouais à Dofus"
Ouais j'ai joué à Dofus, ouais
S: C'était bien Dofus, j'ai fait une vidéo dessus
F: Ben oui je sais je l'ai vu
S: Ah ben voilà
F: C'était la révolution pour moi Dofus.
Bon ben Dofus j'ai pas vu le jour durant une semaine, quoi !
Et je peux jouer... allez on va dire... qu'avec les petits jeux sur console portable, si possible, des trucs comme ça
Mais même avec un Zelda, tu me fous le nouveau Zelda entre les mains
S: Tu le bouffes
F: Ben je vais l'avoir, je vais le bouffer.
Tant que je l'aurai pas bouffé ça sera pas...
S: Tu sortiras pas de chez toi.
Ouais je suis un peu pareil quand j'ai un jeu je le saigne d'un coup.
F: Même Mario Kart, ce put**n de Mario Kart que j'ai acheté sur la 3DS, tu vois
S: Tu l'as mangé entièrement aussi
F: Enfin je l'ai mangé ça oui, en 2 jours.
Mais après il me faut toutes les étoiles,
S: Pour être satisfait quoi
F: de tous les trophées, sinon ça va pas j'ai raté ma vie.
S: Ah à ce point là
F: Ah ben oui
S: C'est 100%
F: Ben oui
S: Ah non
F: Merci pour cette thérapie. Rendez vous demain à... *rires*
F: Tu vas te placer ici et l'idée c'est que je puisse bouger autour de toi.
Euh... je t'ai dit qu'il fallait que... quand tu allais venir tu allais choisir un jeu vidéo dans ta tête
un jeu que je connaissais
S: Oui oui
F: Est ce que tu en as un en tête?
S: C'est bon
F: C'est un jeu vidéo que je connais?
S: Tu connais. C'est sûr.
F. C'est sûr. OK
J'ai pas moyen de le connaitre, c'est bon?
S: Euh non non
F: *Rire* [Imite Simon] Non je ne sais pas, tu as été mettre des micros chez moi *rire*
S: *rires* Non tout est bon j'espère
F: Alors il va se passer des trucs chelous, il faut que tu me fasses confiance OK?
S: OK
F: Alors tu fermes les yeux.
S: Ça roule
F: [voix douce] je vais te faire des petits bisous là.
Non je rigole *rire*
Le mentaliste le plus chelou de la planète . Oui c'est moi qu'est ce qui se passe?!
*rires de Simon*
F: Donc tu fermes les yeux,
tu vas inspirer à fond et expirer à fond. Ça c'est juste pour te détendre
[Inspire et expire ensemble]
Voilà tu vas juste desserrer les mains.
Tu peux faire ça si tu veux ce genre de petits mouvements
S: D'accord
F: Soit bien détendu.
S: C'est bon
F: De temps en temps, tu m'entendra derrière ou sur ta gauche ou devant toi ou sur ta droite peu importe ce qu'il se passe
S: OK
F: Je vais te demander d'imaginer que tu plonges dans ton jeu vidéo,
que tu tombes, concrètement, dans le jeu vidéo
S: D'accord
F: A l'intérieur, tu es plus en face de l'écran, tu es dedans
OK. Tu vas regarder autour de toi ce qu'il y a
S: OK
F: Tu prends le temps de regarder,
et je veux que tu sentes si
si il y a de l'action,
que tu te sentes concerner par cette action.
Si c'est quelques choses où il faut se concentrer,
concentres toi.
Mais essaie, vraiment, de t'imaginer tout le décor du jeu vidéo autour de toi.
S: OK
F: Super. Bouges pas, gardes bien les yeux fermés, bouges pas je vais juste prendre le calepin
S: Je vais prendre en photo et mettre ça sur twitter.
F: Alors là c'est pas le petit calepin, là c'est le gros calepin tu verras
Euh... donc t'imagines tout le décor autour de toi.
euh... si c'est un jeu euh... multijoueurs.
Pas,...  je m'exprime très mal
Si c'est un jeu où il y a pleins d'unités,
par exemple comme euh... l'était Command & conquer,
seul les vrais savent,
tu imagines que tu es une de ces unités là.
Si c'est un jeu... type Zelda tu imagines que tu es Link
Tu vois ce que je veux dire?
S: OK
F: Continues de regarder autour de toi
Je pense qu'on est
Tu vas me confirmer ou m'infirmer ça,
Je pense qu'on est vraiment dans un décor
euh... comment te dire... dans un décor fixe 3D,
où toi tu peux évoluer un peu où tu veux
Est ce que c'est correct?
S: OK on est bon
F: On est pas sur une plateforme type Mario
S: Non
F: OK
F: Et je pense, donc que tu représentes un personnage?
S: Ouais
F: OK
Est ce que tu peux te sentir, de plus en plus dans la peau de ce personnage là
S: OK, ça marche
F: OK
tu es plutôt détendu et... et la position que tu as prise
et intéressante ça veut dire que c'est la position du personnage au repos
OK
euh...
Est ce que ce personnage a des objectifs? Oui il a un objectif
S: Ouais
F: Il a un objectif très précis
F: OK ça marche
Et cette objectif pour ça, faut aller le chercher
et c'est compliqué c'est ça?
S: Effectivement, pas évident.
F: C'est toujours compliqué d'aller chercher cette objectif. OK
euh...
F:  Ah j'aime bien parce que tu bouges la tête
et tu regardes toujours à droite, à gauche ce qui peut se passer,
il y a des ennemies qui peuvent arriver mais
toute la difficulté du jeu n'a pas l'air d'être ici
elle a l'air plus d'être dans une concentration et une précision dans le jeu
Je vais
écrire dans quel jeu tu es, d'après moi
Est ce que sans ouvrir les yeux, tu peux me dire
dans quel jeu tu es dans ta tête
S: Tomb Raider
F: Tomb Raider. Est ce que tu peux ouvrir les yeux
S: Tu te fous de ma gueule. Non!
F: YEEEES
S: C'est pas possible.
F: Put*** mais tu es une meuf en fait.
Tu as été une meuf
S: Ouais ouais,
c'est pour ça quand tu m'as dit prends une position.
J'ai fait, attends c'est quand même vachement différent de moi.
*rires*
F: Et tu as tout assouplis, tu t'es ancré dans le sol.
C'était hyper intéressant, je te recommande de regarder ta propre vidéo
parce que tu vas voir aussi
tes mouvements oculaires derrière les paupières
Tu vas voir la manière dont tu réagis
S: Ouais
F: Forcément, vous, derrière votre écran, même si vous suivez la chaîne
vous dites mais comment il a pu savoir
Je vous le répète
Je garde une partie de la popote pour moi
et c'est comme ça que la chaîne
elle continuera à vous apprendre des choses au fur et à mesure
et c'est comme ça que je peux continuer à vous bluffer et vous faire marrer en spectacle
Ça, ça s'appelle une auto promo
S: Non, je suis assez bluffé
F: Merci d'être venu jusqu'à chez moi aussi parce que
faut savoir que c'est toi qui a bougé
S: Oui mais avec grand plaisir
F: Un de ces 4 on va se faire  une vidéo ensemble,
chez toi.
S: Chez moi oui.
F: Qui fait parti de la série...
S: Exactement, 'A quoi tu joues?'
Et le but c'est que Fabien va venir parler d'un jeu qui l'a énormément marqué en quelques points
et moi je donnerai un point de vue global, plus élargi sur l'univers du jeu en fonction de ce qu'il me dira
F: Et c'est vraiment cool que tu m'aies proposé ça
Merci. Est ce que je peux leur dire de quel jeu je parlerai ou pas?
S: Bien sûr
F:  Ou on le garde?
S: Tu peux le dire, tu peux dire
F: On le garde, on dit
Je vais parler de Civilisation
S: Ahah. Non il y a beaucoup de choses à dire en plus
Civilisations ça risque d'être intéressant
F: J'ai commencé vraiment sur le 1er qui tenait sur 2 disquettes.
et après on s'échangé les trucs pour le code de...
[Rires de Simon]
S: Non les Civilisations c'est une très grande série, il y a beaucoup de choses à dire et il en sort encore aujourd'hui
donc euh... ça risque d'être vraiment cool.
F: Et si la vidéo vous a plu vous pouvez nous le faire savoir en nous laissant un magnifique pouce en l'air
qui fait plaisir, qui fait du bien.
Vous pouvez, également, vous abonner à la chaîne, c'est par ici avant de partir.
ça doit être aussi par là
Et rendez vous demain à 17h
Tchao !